today's video is kindly sponsored by
guardio find out more later on hey 42
here we humans have a natural desire to
belong which is probably why we're
constantly forming groups and societies
to belong to
getting together with people who share
common interests can be a rich and
rewarding experience
there are quite literally millions of
clubs and associations to choose from
and they are as diverse and in many
cases bizarre as humanity itself
many associations have prerequisites for
membership
take for instance the ejection tie club
which is for pilots who've survived
being ejected from an airplane that's a
pretty nice group by anyone standards
but membership numbers are surprisingly
high at around 6000 people worldwide
pilots who've tried and failed to eject
from their stricken planes could
potentially be eligible to join another
unusual club instead the uttar pradesh
association of dead people
the group was founded by lal buhari
after his application for a bank loan
was denied on the ground that he was in
fact deceased
that came as a bit of a shock to poor
old buhari who considered himself to be
in pretty good health but it turned out
his uncle had bribed a state official to
have buhari declared dead in order to
steal his inheritance
as a result buhari was considered
legally if not biologically deceased for
almost 20 years
that might sound like another fairly
niche group but the association
currently boasts a staggering 20 000
members
all of whom are legally dead
[Music]
luckily you don't need to be deceased or
the survivor of a freak accident to find
a group of like-minded people
for example simply being a white
supremacist with an interest in
fundamentalist christianity and burning
crosses should be enough to get you
through the doors of the ku klux klan
a notorious hate group whose membership
numbers peaked at around 4 million in
the mid 1920s
that was about 3.5 percent of the u.s
population at the time
of course if you aren't pale skinned and
a fervent protestant your chances of
acceptance into the kkk are dismal
but those odds weren't enough to deter
ron stallworth the first and last black
man to become a card carrying member of
the ku klux klan
now the internet is a wonderful thing
but as the world becomes more connected
the risk of being scammed or hacked
increases with time it's never been more
important to protect yourself whilst
browsing the web and guardio offers that
protection in an effective first line of
defense model detecting threats in real
time before they reach your browser and
cause harm as opposed to traditional
methods that remove them from your
device once they've gained access
researching all these videos often takes
me to very strange corners of the
internet and i come across a lot of
dodgy websites
many of them are there to do me harm
whether it's through phishing attempts
that try to steal my social media or
banking details or fake tech support
scams
so that's why i started using guardio so
i no longer have to think before i click
it was super easy to set up i added the
guardio browser extension then i ran the
free security scan to detect existing
frets and that's it join over 1 million
guardio users who've taken control of
their online safety and never have to
worry about visiting harmful sites again
to enjoy worry-free browsing and run a
free security scan in just a few clicks
to see what threats are on your browser
use my link in the description and
you'll receive an extra discount for the
full browsing protection which includes
a seven day free trial visit guard dot
io
42 today hurry up before the offer ends
ron was used to being in the minority
born in 1953 he joined the colorado
springs police department as a cadet in
1972. and became the first black
american to graduate from the training
program two years later from the
beginning ron wanted to work undercover
and soon enough he was presented with
the chance to do just that when he was
asked to attend a speech given by kwame
tor a prominent civil rights activist at
a local nightclub a few times during
tori's speech ron caught himself
shouting and chanting in agreement so
it's fair to say it probably wasn't the
most challenging undercover assignments
in history but
that would soon change
the successful completion of the kwame
tour job saw ron being posted to his
department's intelligence unit where he
continued to blaze a trail becoming the
first black undercover narcotics
detective in colorado springs police
department history it was in late 1978
that ron came across a kkk recruitment
drive in the classified section of a
local newspaper
who knows what the ad said perhaps
something like a group of white bigoted
crescents seek new members for carrying
burning tortures and shooting cans love
of silly hats is a must
any interested individuals were to
contact ken o'dell the organizer of the
colorado springs chapter of the clan
expecting to be sent a brochure or a
pamphlet of some kind ron was caught off
guard when he received a telephone call
two weeks later
the man on the line was ken odell
himself and he wanted to inquire further
as to run's motivations for joining the
clan
it was around this time that a few
glaring problems with ron's plan to
investigate the kkk first came to light
firstly
there was no plan and secondly he used
his real name in the letter
luckily ron was both quick-witted and
very good on the phone he launched into
an angry rant about pretty much every
ethnic minority he could think of then
rounded things off with an improvised
story about an impertinent black man who
dared to date his sister
needless to say all of this was music to
ken odell's big racist ears it was clear
that ron was just the type of guy the
clan was looking for but before ron
could celebrate his small victory
ken dropped a bombshell
he wanted to meet his new recruit in
person
of course a face-to-face meeting
presented ron with a minor problem
namely that far from being a white
supremacist he wasn't even white
keen to avoid an impromptu lynching ron
quickly set about finding himself a body
double the plan was simple he will
continue to play white ron over the
phone and in any written correspondence
but whenever he was acquired on clan
business in person a suitably white
colleague of his called chuck was
drafted in
there was unfortunately one small issue
with this approach
ron and chuck had completely different
sounding voices
surprisingly on only one occasion during
the entire seven and a half month
investigation did anyone actually notice
this obvious vocal discrepancy
during one of ron's phone calls with ken
the ku klux klan boss asked ron why his
voice sounded so strange and ron calmly
explained that he was suffering from a
sinus infection despite the fact the two
men had seen each other just hours
before
ken accepted the explanation without the
slightest hint of suspicion even going
so far as to kindly offer some treatment
advice
what a stand-up guy
so thanks to a combination of sheer
stupidity good acting and
perhaps the poor quality of phone lines
in the late 70s
the clan remained convinced there was
only one run
a man who suffered with allergies
despite his perfect iron genes
with chuck's help ron had successfully
infiltrated the clan and he began to
extract as much information as possible
whilst monitoring any potentially
subversive activities
motivated by a lifetime of racism ron
threw himself into his assignment he
worked hard to endear himself to his
clan colleagues who he described as
not the brightest bulbs in the socket
the bulb that shone the dimmest though
was local leader ken
in ron's own words the man was a total
idiot
soon after their initial meeting ken
invited ron over to his house to take
part in an important clan meeting
chuck of course attended in ron's place
wearing a wire so ron could hear what
was going on
it turned out the meeting was to discuss
the logistics of burning four 17-foot
crosses at strategic locations nearby
all of those assembled agreed that it
would be a deeply moving religious
experience but thanks to ron and his
undercover operation the cross-burnings
were thwarted as well as hoodwinking the
palm springs chapter of the kkk
ron also managed to pull the wall over
the eyes of the clan's global leader at
the time david duke who carried the
awesome title of grand wizard despite
his clear lack of a hogwarts education
ron was accidentally introduced to duke
when he phoned the clan's head offices
in the hope of expediting his official
acceptance into the organization
clan membership would mean that ron was
eligible to participate in all clan
activities so he was eager to speed up
the process ron's enthusiasm clearly
struck a chord with duke he promised to
personally see to it that ron had his
membership card and certificate posted
out to him asap to this day ron carries
his membership card which was signed by
the grand wizard himself in his wallet
it seems that ron genuinely charmed the
clan leader and their excellent rapport
would lead to one of the most unlikely
relationships of all time with the two
chatting on the phone once or twice a
week
ron would massage the grand wizard's ego
and duke would reveal all kinds of
information during their calls every now
and then ron couldn't help but bait the
duke even asking him how he could be
sure that a smart-ass black man wouldn't
fool him over the phone by posing as a
white man
duke confidently explained that black
people talked differently so there was
no chance something like that could ever
happen
wizard my ass
duke later visited colorado springs for
a pr blitz which happened to coincide
with ron's induction into the clan and
in a strange twist of fate the real ron
stalworth was assigned to protect duke
after he received death threats
when stalworth met duke he explains that
he didn't agree with his philosophy or
political ideology but that his beliefs
wouldn't interfere with ron's ability to
ensure duke's safety ron made no effort
to disguise his voice but duke never
made the connection between his
protection officer and the man he spoke
with so frequently over the phone at one
point in the day stalwart asked for a
photo with duke saying no one would ever
believe that he had been the grand
wizard's bodyguard
brilliantly it was ron's white body
double chuck who took that polaroid
photo
and just as it was being taken
stallworth put his arms around duke and
another clansmen
being the massive racist that he was the
duke wasn't best pleased with this turn
of events and he tried to stop ron
leaving with the photo at which point
ron played the police card and threatens
to arrest duke for assaulting an officer
during their next phone conversation ron
asked if anything interesting had
happened on his visit to colorado
springs to which duke replied with a
racial slur-infested story about a cop
who'd threatened to put him behind bars
thanks to ron and chuck's combined
efforts the undercover mission revealed
a lot of useful intelligence about the
clan's activities in colorado springs
and beyond during the course of the
investigation a number of clan members
were revealed to be part of the military
including two senior members of the
north american aerospace defense command
with top-level security clearance
both men were reassigned
the undercover agents were also
successful in preventing the detonation
of a nail bomb in a colorado springs gay
bar
a plan which had been cooked up by the
kkk and the local neo-nazi group
in the end ron and chuck were perhaps
too good at their jobs
recognizing ron's dedication and loyalty
ken odell eventually put him forward as
the future chapter leader for colorado
springs at which point it was decided it
was probably best if the investigation
were closed and all evidence of its
existence destroyed
after all it would certainly take a bit
of explaining if word ever got out that
a couple of policemen were paid up
members of the kkk
ron complied with his orders but he kept
his membership card and the polaroid of
him and duke as souvenirs
remarkably the world would probably
never have heard this incredible tale
had ron nut revealed the investigation
in a 2006 interview
the story will go on to inspire the 2018
film black k klansman and serve as a
source of much red-faced embarrassment
for the ku klux klan
if you've ever wondered why grown men
wear pillowcases over their heads
perhaps that's why
thanks for watching